une console tu veux te faire prendre ou
quoi je crois qu'il y a un problème
c'est verrouillé je voulais vérifier
c'est ça oui
il se passe quelque chose ça s'est
répandu dans le monde entier c'est une
sorte de mélange d'un virus de jeux
vidéo avec le code
c'est quoi ces trucs qui viennent de
notre jeu vidéo
je crois que Maman et Papa sont des
espions sans blague
on doit trouver nos parents tout de
suite
salut les loulous si vous êtes là et que
vous êtes seul c'est que les choses ont
atrocement mal tourné on avait hâte de
vous faire découvrir cet abri il y a de
la nourriture et des modules
d'entraînement comment devenir espion je
vais être le meilleur espion de tous les
temps tu as réussi
[Musique]
loupé puisque c'est nous qui avons
provoqué cet apocalypse c'est à nous
d'arrêter les méchants et de sauver le
monde
alors qu'est-ce qu'on attend
activation des bottes magnétiques
le temps presse on va y arriver une
seconde on entre dans le jeu non non non
il nous faut un plan B
[Musique]
on a affaire à un ennemi très
intelligent on commence
mais pourquoi il est autant de méchants
c'est plus marrant comme ça
[Musique]